des films sur le sénégal projeté devant
trente spectateurs attentifs
jusque là rien d'anormal pourtant un
bruit de fond intrigue
ici pas d'électricité pour faire
fonctionner le vidéoprojecteur il faut
pédaler et ce sont les spectateurs qui
s'y colle je fais du vélo un peu de
temps en temps donc comparé au vtt dans
les bois est tous là c'est facile quoi
on et puis et puis on se rend
compte que l'on fait l'énergie ont fait
tout ce qu'il faut pour que les gens à
côté soit en train de regarder le film
rigole donc c'était c'était vraiment une
expérience extraordinaire
[Musique]
vincent hanrion est le fondateur de
signer cyclo les films projetés raconte
son histoire en selle de six mois passés
au sénégal à vélo nous retrouvons
vincent quelques heures avant la
projection pour une séance
d'installation 80 kilos de matériels à
mettre en place
aux aurores voilà une demi heure plus
tard tout est prêt le vélo que générer
de l'électricité
il ya une dynamo qui est relié en
contact sur le pneu arrière donc là
vraiment quand les gens vont se mettent
à pédales et voilà ça va entraîner cette
dynamo skis
générer de l'électricité l'électricité
va courir le long du câble jusqu'à une
boîte qu'on a appelé le hibou est en
fait le hibou lui va venir stocker un
petit peu d'énergie
il va venir réguler cette énergie va
venir la convertir pour venir alimenter
du matériel sonore donc on l'a on voit
là de la paire d'enceintes et puis du
matériel vidéo
le vidéoprojecteur un système de cinéma
itinérant mise au point par vincent lui
même et son association signé cyclo
l'idée c'était de liées aux voyages à
vélo et aux voyages d'aventuré vélo la
diffusion de films alors soit pour des
justes pour du divertissement pour la
partage culturel soit pour répondre à
des vrais besoins d'accès à
l'information dans des zones isolées où
il y en a forcément une altiste et je
n'aurais jamais cru qu'un tel
enthousiasme aurait pu naître une simple
idée du voyage avaient le profil